imagina que estás tranquilamente sentado
en un restaurante o en una cafetería y
que de repente se empieza a escuchar un
tiroteo a pocos metros de distancia
seguro seguro que se te quitaría el
apetito verdad pues amigos
desgraciadamente este tipo de
situaciones son comunes en muchas
ciudades centroamericanas ciudades donde
la seguridad brilla por su ausencia
en 2018 42 de las 50 ciudades más
violentas del mundo se encontraban en
latinoamérica y de ellas dos estaban en
honduras unah en guatemala y otra en el
salvador tan solo en 2017 en
centroamérica se registraron más de
14.500 homicidios la inmensa mayoría de
ellos más del 90% tuvieron lugar en tres
países conocidos como el triángulo norte
el salvador honduras y guatemala
escalofriante no os parece ahora bien
porque la violencia es algo tan común en
esta parte del mundo cuál es el origen
de sus altas tasas de criminalidad
acaso centroamérica siempre ha sido una
región tan violenta atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os hago una pregunta os habéis fijado
alguna vez en lo curioso que es el mapa
de américa fijaos un momento
centroamérica es todo un puente entre
américa del sur y américa del norte y no
sólo metafóricamente también
literalmente y eso amigos eso es algo
que tiene consecuencias
el hecho de que centroamérica sea el
puente es algo que lo ha convertido en
el mayor corredor de mercancías ilícitas
del mundo mercancías producidas en
sudamérica hablamos sobre todo de la
cocaína
ni más ni menos que el 90 por ciento de
la cocaína que entra en eeuu el mayor
mercado mundial pasa por centroamérica
pero no creáis que esta es la única
actividad ilegal que está asentada allí
para nada la trata de personas el
tráfico de inmigrantes ilegales y el
tráfico de menores son también
actividades con gran presencia en esta
región y como os podéis imaginar todo
esto es algo que va acompañado de una
gran cantidad de crimen organizado de
organizaciones criminales que controlan
gestionan y luchan entre sí por la
hegemonía de todos estos negocios
hablamos en realidad de toda una
industria de una industria con todas sus
letras con sus gerentes sus
administradores sus abogados sus
asesores corporativos sus estrategias de
diversificación y de inversión una
industria que cada vez más está
estableciendo en centroamérica los
cárteles mexicanos trasladan el 90% de
su actividad a centroamérica según un
estudio veréis el aumento de la presión
del estado en méxico durante los últimos
años ha hecho que este tipo de mafias
quieran establecerse en países con
estados menos fuertes y vigilantes y
sabéis que lo cierto es que estos grupos
estas macro empresas del crimen han
conseguido hacerse con gran parte de
centroamérica atentos
[Música]
méxico exportador de crimen a
centroamericano amigos mexico o bueno
mejor dicho los cárteles mexicanos están
poco a poco convirtiéndose en los
líderes en los mayores dueños del
negocio de los estupefacientes en toda
latinoamérica y desde luego hace ya
tiempo que compiten de tú a tú con los
grupos colombianos
y por supuesto los carteles mexicanos
también controlan ya buena parte de las
principales rutas de transporte de
mercancías ilegales y eso eso
necesariamente significa controlar
centroamérica
ahora bien pongámonos un momento en la
mente de uno de estos grandes campos
imagínate que tú eres uno de ellos cuál
es la forma más rápida de controlar el
territorio centroamericano cómo lograría
es instalarte y dominar ese lugar
[Música]
exacto una buena posibilidad es
establecer alianzas con los grupos
criminales autóctonos los grupos
criminales que ya operaban en el terreno
grupos que tienen la infraestructura los
contactos y el conocimiento del
territorio que tú necesitas hablamos de
grupos con una sola filosofía trabajar
con la parte que más dólares suelte
vamos no creo que sorprenda ya lo sabéis
todos es el poder del dólar
pero ahora bien como y porque
centroamérica se ha convertido en algo
así como un gran campo para explotar
para los narcos mexicanos amigos para
responder a esta pregunta tenemos que
remontarnos hasta los años 90
[Música]
la época clave para el cambio de
protagonistas se produjo entre los años
1991 y 1993 que es cuando el cartel de
medellín sufre sus mayores derrotas la
caída de pablo escobar y de los
principales capos de este cartel supuso
perder también la enorme influencia y
poder que tenían en centroamérica
gracias a sus alianzas con grupos
locales que operaban a sueldo para ellos
y eso eso fue la gran ventana de
oportunidad para los grupos mexicanos
que por supuesto aprovecharon ese vacío
para entrar de lleno en centroamérica
con el objetivo de controlar ese puente
tan importante que unen los centros de
producción con los centros de consumo
pero claro seguro seguro que alguno de
vosotros está pensando pero enrique
vamos a ver en méxico hay varios
carteles diferentes no supone es un
problema que cartel controla la ruta de
transporte centroamérica quien se ha
hecho dueño del territorio
pues sí amigos tenéis razón y
precisamente por eso tras la llegada de
los mexicanos a centroamérica este lugar
se convierte en una especie de campo de
batalla entre los diferentes carteles
que luchaban a cara de perro por el
control de las rutas de transporte y
precisamente esa fue una de las causas
que explica por qué la violencia
centroamérica aumentó drásticamente
hasta que las fichas pues fueron
alcanzando su posición final se fueron
los diferentes carteles repartiendo el
territorio por así decirlo los cárteles
mexicanos se convirtieron en grandes
exportadores de violencia y crimen hacia
sus vecinos del sur fijaos por ejemplo
en el caso de honduras
[Música]
ya lo veis las luchas de poder de los
carteles mexicanos y las bandas locales
para incrementar su influencia y lograr
el control del negocio explican buena
parte del aumento del crimen durante
esos años ahora bien aparecemos por un
momento las grandes cifras y centrémonos
en la calle cómo afectan exactamente
todas estas batallas entre cárteles y
grupos criminales centroamericanos a la
seguridad de la gente a la vida diaria
en el país atentos
cuando la violencia no encuentra enemigo
ya lo habéis visto el triángulo norte
centroamericano tiene las tasas de
criminalidad más elevadas del mundo por
eso una pregunta esencial es tiene
solución esta situación qué diantres
necesita la región para alcanzar cierta
paz y estabilidad
pues amigos lo cierto es que este
objetivo se antoja muy pero que muy
complicado porque presta atención el
hermano del presidente hondureño es
declarado culpable de narcotráfico narco
vincula al presidente de honduras con el
tráfico de drogas
fabio lobo hijo del ex presidente de
honduras a la cárcel por narcotráfico
una juez del distrito sur de nueva york
lo condenó a 24 años de cárcel el ex
presidente saca de el salvador condenado
a dos años de cárcel por soborno con
semejante panorama de corrupción
narcotráfico institucionalizado y otros
comportamientos despreciables a ver
quién es el guapo que se pone a luchar
contra el crimen si es que es el propio
crimen el que está al mando vamos a ver
si las mismísimas altas esferas de poder
en centroamérica tienen vínculos tan
cercanos tan estrechos con los grandes
criminales como demonios van a luchar
contra ellos
y ya no es que puedan o no puedan sino
que simplemente pues no quieren es una
cuestión de incentivos nadie
absolutamente nadie quiere acabar con la
gallina de los huevos de oro sin embargo
un momento porque a pesar de esta cruda
realidad lo cierto es que durante los
últimos años centroamérica está
experimentando una paulatina reducción
de las tasas de homicidios lo que ha
llevado a muchos políticos a sacar pecho
claro que lo cierto es que la mayoría de
los casos esto no ha sido gracias al
gobierno sino a pesar de él sin ir más
lejos echemos un vistazo al caso del
salvador
[Música]
por ejemplo en el salvador en 2018 se
registraron un 15% menos de homicidios
que en el año anterior pero aún así la
cifra es todavía una auténtica salvajada
tres mil trescientos cuarenta homicidios
en un año en un país de menos de seis
millones y medio de habitantes el
salvador es el país con la tasa de
homicidios más alta de la región la más
peligrosa del planeta es decir podríamos
considerar a este país como el más
peligroso del mundo
pero aunque lo haya espoleado lo cierto
es que todo esto es algo que viene de
lejos de mucho antes de que los cárteles
mexicanos irrumpieron en centroamérica
os hablamos de ello hace tiempo aquí en
visual político las maras son peligrosos
grupos criminales de pandilleros muchos
originados en los ángeles dedicados
sobre todo al tráfico de estupefacientes
y armas al blanqueo de capitales al
tráfico de inmigrantes y al proxenetismo
han sido desde los años 60 uno de los
mayores retos en la seguridad del
salvador la mara salvatrucha o ms-13 y
barrio 18 son las dos principales que
como no podía ser de otra manera están
enfrentadas y llevan un montón de años
intentando controlar el territorio de
las ciudades salvadoreñas para llevar a
cabo sus actividades ilícitas
esta pelea por el territorio ha regado
de sangre y sufrimiento al pueblo del
salvador
y por supuesto estas maras siguen
plenamente activas entonces porque la
criminalidad se está reduciendo en los
últimos años pues fijaos porque por ahí
van los tiros nunca mejor dicho narcos
usan amarres y pandilleros para dominar
centroamérica
[Música]
si veréis paradójicamente esta alianza
entre maras y carteles podría estar
explicando buena parte de la reducción
de los homicidios porque como es esto
posible pues veréis la respuesta es
compleja pero simplificando un poco
podemos decir que actualmente las maras
están actuando como sucursales de los
carteles mexicanos más importantes como
es el caso del cartel de sinaloa o los
zetas
curiosamente esto podría estar
provocando que parte de las fuerzas de
estas maras estén operando en campos más
amplios protegiendo las actividades de
los cárteles mexicanos alejándose así de
las calles digamos que hay negocios más
grandes que extorsionar al comerciante
de la esquina y no sólo eso además los
cárteles mexicanos se han dado cuenta de
que las maras son tremendamente eficaces
en el control de las ciudades y en
infundir el mayor temor posible así que
están reclutando efectivos de entre las
maras y trasladándolos a mexico para
apoyar sus propias actividades y también
para formar a su propia gente vamos que
los están fichando de esta forma los
mexicanos han introducido a las maras en
el negocio del narcotráfico
internacional a gran escala pero que
están aportando exactamente las maras a
los cárteles mexicanos pues
evidentemente nada bueno les estaré
enseñando las formas más horribles
crueles y despiadadas de tratar a sus
adversarios técnicas que están
trasladando y llevando a la práctica en
el mismísimo méxico
en fin creo que ahora ya podéis entender
mejor porque se ha reducido la
criminalidad durante los últimos años y
si desgraciadamente en gran medida no ha
tenido nada que ver con los gobiernos ni
con el plan para centroamérica de los
eeuu sino con las propias dinámicas de
esta industria del crimen
[Música]
pero bueno seguro estoy seguro que
llegados a este punto muchos estáis
pensando que esto se ha ido de madre
maras y carteles colaborando gobiernos
comprados y con intereses criminales
fuerzas de seguridad ineficaces y
corruptas tribunales vendidos con
semejante panorama creéis que el
salvador y centroamérica en general
tienen alguna posibilidad para escapar
de este círculo vicioso que pueden hacer
por ejemplo los salvadoreños para dejar
de ser el país más peligroso del mundo
pues amigos lamento deciros que no
parece una tarea nada pero que nada
fácil
pero quién sabe quizás la llegada de
este hombre muy pero que muy conocido
por dirigir su gobierno golpe de tuit
puede suponer un paso adelante y
demostrar con ello que uno de los
problemas de centroamérica sino el
problema más importante es que no hay
voluntad política
[Música]
pero de julio
allí
bukele un candidato independiente logra
la victoria en las elecciones del
salvador
bukele llegó al poder a principios de
este mismo año 2019 con una promesa
estrella hacer del salvador un país
menos corrupto y más seguro lo
conseguirá solo el tiempo lo dirá pero
de momento parece que está tomando pasos
decididos para que así sea claro que con
los políticos latinoamericanos bueno uno
nunca sabe antes de lanzarse a la
piscina siempre siempre es mejor esperar
los resultados aquí las previsiones
sobre todo si son optimistas valen de
poco y os voy a contar el salvador-
lanza una comisión anticorrupción
inspirada por guatemala
y ojo porque la corrupción no es un
problema menor en esta región luchar
contra la corrupción es un paso
necesario para desvincular al poder del
crimen pero bueno llegados a este punto
ya hemos visto porque los políticos no
siempre tienen motivos para sacar pecho
por mucho que las tasas de homicidios se
reduzca también hemos visto como en
honduras hoy por hoy hay poco espacio
para la esperanza y también como el
salvador en cambio parece estar ante
toda una oportunidad sin embargo amigos
en toda esta ecuación de crimen y poder
nos falta otro país centroamericano un
país que no forma parte del triángulo
norte pero que ha visto un incremento
dramático de la violencia en los últimos
tiempos una violencia en este caso muy
diferente porque amigos y el narco no es
la única enfermedad que amenaza y azota
centroamérica atentos
que se vaya a bajarse
nicaragua el fin del sueño
nos lo hemos contado en diferentes
vídeos e incluso le dimos uno de
nuestros premios visual polític 2018 a
la oposición a las protestas a los
movimientos estudiantiles en nicaragua
se da un fenómeno que no sucede en
muchos otros países latinoamericanos que
es el del uso de la violencia como forma
de control político
[Música]
un escenario similar al que podemos
encontrar en venezuela y que ha
terminado de un plumaje con el mito de
que nicaragua era la excepción un país
seguro en la región más peligrosa del
mundo por ejemplo en 2017 nicaragua tuvo
tan solo 7 homicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes cuando por ejemplo en
honduras encontrábamos cifras de 40 en
el salvador de 51 y en guatemala de 28
la diferencia es notable pero eso eso
amigos no convierte a nicaragua ni por
asomo en un lugar seguro para vivir y el
tiempo nos lo ha demostrado
el frente sandinista de liberación
nacional el partido oficialista ha
penetrado completamente en los
organismos de poder del estado
politizando los a base de enchufar a
personas afines y utilizando a
verdaderos grupos paramilitares para
reprimir
literalmente el tirano nicaragüense
daniel ortega ha comenzado a emplear a
matones para que le hagan el trabajo más
sucio a la policía y el ejército durante
las protestas
y si desde el punto de vista político e
institucional esta es una de las peores
decisiones que un gobernante puede tomar
alarma en nicaragua por ola de crímenes
con saña que llevan el sello de los
paramilitares de daniel ortega en 2018
los índices de violencia se dispararon
con la brutal represión de los
manifestantes civiles por parte del
régimen del presidente daniel ortega
y qué os parece si todos estos matones
fuesen a la casa de maduro de ortega y
les hiciesen una demostración de sus
habilidades y es que amigos en el
momento en que un gobierno empieza a
usar fuerzas irregulares para reprimir
entonces entonces crea las condiciones
para legalizar y normalizar la violencia
y la impunidad a nivel general por así
decirlo de golpe y porrazo se abren las
compuertas del crimen
lo hemos visto en venezuela y lo estamos
empezando a ver en nicaragua en fin ya
lo veis el crimen la corrupción y la
falta de seguridad son los grandes males
que están condenando centroamérica en
muchos casos sino en todos con el
beneplácito y la complicidad de los
propios poderes políticos
el caso es que queríamos hacer este
vídeo para que pudieras entender mejor
qué demonios ocurre con la violencia en
esta región del mundo la región más
peligrosa del planeta y también para que
supiese es que se esconde detrás de la
reducción en el número de homicidios que
se ha producido en los últimos años así
que llegados a este punto turno para ti
crees que la seguridad en centroamérica
es un sueño imposible puede realmente la
región deshacerse de la maldición del
narcotráfico y el crimen organizado y
muy especialmente para nuestros amigos
centroamericanos cómo estáis viviendo
esta situación en vuestro día a día como
pensáis que afecta a vuestros países
como creéis que se podría solucionar nos
interesa muchísimo vuestra opinión así
que no olvidéis responder en los
comentarios y por supuesto si este vídeo
os ha resultado interesante tampoco
dudéis en darle a like y suscribiros a
visual polític por cierto en próximos
vídeos que llegará muy pronto hablaremos
sobre los cambios que se están
produciendo en la región y hablaremos
también de los cambios que se están
dando
en el salvador que es algo que nos
estáis pidiendo un montón en fin una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]